Thanks all right good morning it's great
to be here it's nice to see so many
familiar faces and in some faces that I
haven't yet had the pleasure of meeting
we are the slide before yell tech I was
a PhD student at Yale some years ago I
thought they would never ever ever in a
million years ago to a conference where
I see the words Yale and tech on the
title slide for the day so first of all
I just want to say congratulations to to
Victor and to rich lil hail and to alina
groups go and all their colleagues for
putting putting this together all of
them each of them are spawn from ye I
the organization that I'm a part of and
I think that the fact that we have
fellows that are now five six seven
eight years out and are starting to come
into their own and figure out how to
better assemble us i think is proof of
the critical mass that we're hoping to
create so so Thank You Victor um for
those of you who've heard me talk I
usually spend a few minutes talking
about just yei the Yale entrepreneurial
Institute and what we do at the
University you'll get a few minutes of
that for me but I'm also here
representing the full university because
victor is such a slave driver he only
gave us a brief window and time to talk
about what's actually happening on the
university so I'm here as a spokesperson
not just for why I but for many of our
partners who have in the last few years
really begun to scale their programs as
well for those of you who haven't been
initiated to what we are we are a
university department we work for Yale
and we provide mentorship grant grant
money ultimately accelerator experiences
for students who we think students and
faculty who have technologies and
service ideas that we believe can scale
access to the alumni community
especially those who are interested to
in serving as investors and mentors and
ultimately we have a small fund that
sits alongside why I as well we're with
the help of our investment board we're
able to make modest investments in those
teams number of people around the room
have gone through why I I won't point
them out by name you'll meet them during
the day
who have been become successful
entrepreneurs founders themselves and
help give rise to more than one hundred
and thirty or forty million dollars in
investment dollars up till now I'll pick
on a few just because I think stories
are more important than none about
particular teams are more important than
talking about programs on some place in
this room is our two blond guys my name
of Bob Casey and rich little hail and
when they came to us back in two
thousand and early 2008 they wanted to
build a company around vitamin water or
some vitamin water derivative that idea
ran out of steam fairly quickly and then
they came back within only a few months
time with the idea of starting up a
company to do electronic recycling jump
ahead five or six years and they found
themselves the acquisition target of a
billion-dollar company who was
interested in them not just for the
services they had created but for the
software they had built as well and
yesterday to some great fanfare and I
think several hundred likes on Facebook
Bob Casey retired from his company and
announced that he's going back to
harvard business school this fall so Bob
I'm sorry you're going to Harvard but
it's nice that you're continuing your
education so great we've also had impact
at Yale not just with pure student
stirrups but with students who've been
working with faculty and I think for
those of you who haven't heard this
story we have the pleasure of working
very closely with students from the
School of Management and Justin Borgman
who was a student in the 2009-2010 time
frame he got together with one of our
computer science professors Daniela body
to create a company called adapt which
was doing things did things in the in
the database space that had never been
done before with yell technology and
while that company was eventually sold
to an acquirer just a few years ago
giving Daniel and giving Daniel and exit
and Justin a means to come back to
continue his own education I think we
saw in that experience of students
working with faculty a better way for
the university to actually advanced
technologies out of the labs as well and
there are quite a few stories that are
now
um developing on the campus sort of in
the in the in the same model as what
adapted just 23 years ago we came to
understand that we are why I Yale the
campus is not the final finishing school
for many of the ideas that that come
from the student body and I think it was
because of Aaron furor and what his team
did was panorama education that we came
to understand that being and being at
Yale and being part of the why I
experience in many cases is nothing more
than a prelude to some greater more
domain-specific experience experience
which is what at panorama went on to do
after graduating excuse me after
graduating from ye I they went on to a Y
Combinator and quite a bit of Fame with
investors of national national note so
within the last two years because we
were finding ourselves challenged with
all these bright people who would
consume vast amounts of grant dollars
from the University they still needed
first investment so with the help of a
few investment partners we were able
yell and Connecticut innovations and
first in agri were able to cobble
together three million dollars and with
great with great success we've managed
to find a small handful of teams over
the last 18 months twenty months that
we've made modest first investments in
hundred thousand dollars no more and
this has been something which has not
only been instrumental for helping the
teams but also in a in a fair number of
cases led to those teams going on 22
real series a series a investments in
short order afterwards but I'm going to
stop talking about why I because I
promised you I wasn't going to make this
a commercial for my unit the university
is much different now than it was when
we first started why I back in the
summer of 2007 and I think most notable
among the changes is ted schneider and
kyle jensen at the school of management
have landed with quite a bit of fanfare
in creating an entrepreneurship
experience / curriculum at
so when that we never had before and I
think the fact that after years of why I
being alone in the wilderness so to
speak we now have an academic colleague
and academic champion at the University
to give us a curricular route for where
people can go for for training and for
pedagogy I think this has been very
instrumental very important to us and
kyle and and jennifer McFadden who are
here in the audience you'll meet them
today think deep thoughts not just about
the teams that are from the School of
Management but actually teams from all
across the university I think we've had
a fair number of students from
undergraduate and from other
professional schools all of whom have
been touched by som and for those of you
who have academic aspirations kyle is in
fact looking for someone in one person
full time in several person for part
time to join him on the faculty at som
so if you see yourself as being a not
only a founder of a company but also
someone who's willing to become a
teacher and has a love love of learning
and a love of dealing with people with
virtually no venture experience please
see Kyle for more details probably the
the broadest experience that I've
witnessed in the last few years has been
the success of my colleagues from my
school from engineering over at the sea
Eid the maker lab at Yale and what we've
all witnessed is the fact that students
at Yale even though they don't
necessarily see themselves as
engineering majors Vince Welch in ski
and Joe's inter who runs the Eid have
found that they've been able to create a
membership program which is inspired
more than a thousand students to join
them to participate in the
extracurricular programs to take classes
and workshops there to actually get
their hands dirty in making things and
this is something that our unit alena
grips go in myself we look at this
what's happening at CID and realize that
there are things we have to learn why I
in terms of creating a greater
membership function especially for the
Yale College community and we won't we
won't leave at our friends in the
medical school we have been blessed with
the creation of a medical device
accelerator at Yale to which goes by the
acronym cbit we call it C bit
this is run by Peter Shulman and Chris
loose and what the what these folks are
doing at the medical school is looking
for innovative and scalable medical
device technologies which which can get
to market and in the last just year see
bit and why I together have actually
collaborated on more than a dozen
different technologies and ideas that
we're hopeful eventually bringing into
either one of their one of their
programs or one of ours and even though
they're based in medicine just the same
as what I said a few moments ago about
see Eid see if it works with with
students and faculty from all across the
university not just from the from the
School of Medicine not to be left out
the school of public health because they
have a mission of impacting global
health are very very inspired to think
about the venture creation experience as
a way to further their goals to and for
creating more sustainable means of
providing goods and services to the
developing world and led by Mar decline
who's there deputy deputy director we
have partnered on several different with
several different teams through what's
called a thorn prize at public health
and brought those teams into why I for
further mentorship and guidance on the
on the on the faculty side we're even
beginning to talk about partnering with
the folks in drug discovery over on the
west campus in this efforts led by Craig
Cruz and he and we together are thinking
about ways that we can help companies in
that space as well so um that's just a
snapshot of a few of a number of centers
across the university that why I is
working with so I think we have we have
bright days ahead and I just wanted to
leave you our contact information should
any of you be interested in coming on
alumni this is as as mentors or advisors
or perhaps seeing what kind of ventures
were starting for purpose of the
purposes of investment so thank you very
much